for the best film in a foreign language
technically that means that the dialogue
is not in English sometimes to call them
foreign films now you and I know that
makes no difference what country a
picture was shot in or where the
producer was born or the tongue the
actors speak for the language of film is
the same the world over images that
capture the truth and the fantasies
about life this year the nominees for
best foreign language film are from the
Netherlands
the assault fauncewater maker director
from France Betty blue jean jacques
vineyards director from canada the
decline of American Empire
Denny our Kong they're ready from
Czechoslovakia my sweet little village
jury mensen director Bastian
38 Wolfgang Luke director the winner is
the winner is the Netherlands or the
assault
it's a great honor to be to standing
here at the great pleasure as well I
think the members of the Academy for
bestowing this of the picture of the
assault I think all my friends who work
this me on both sides of the camera
because without their help and their
talent I would be sitting here and I
think my friends better have gone along
the URL Globus from Kenan who made this
all possible and gave me all freedom and
I think my friend Lloyd lactic as well
and this Oscar this foreign language
Oscar has a request
imagine that foreign language pictures
this country are screened with subtitles
and Oscars request is please don't let
subtitles scare you off as much as they
seem to do from time to time because
Oscar things that is worthwhile and
interesting to see also from time to
time what people think and how people
acted foreign languages I think you're
very very about did I pause later